hey guys it's inka so as most of you
know i have been doing a lot of
viral slash trendy foods over the years
a lot of really crazy things
but all of them super wildly visual so i
hope you enjoy this video
i also wanted to let you know that a
couple friends and i have launched a new
channel
called about to eat where we'll be doing
a lot of
fun food adventures so please definitely
check that out as well
and i will see you in the next video
this
is 16k strands of dragonbeard's candy
guys
look at that
[Music]
ready hi i'm inka today we're going to
try and make this
super cool looking cotton candy called
dragon beards candy
this candy originated from china
apparently ancient emperors used to eat
this
think of cotton candy that's made purely
from your hands
that's pretty cool success rate is super
super low but we're still gonna give it
a shot let's do it the ingredients are
pretty simple it's basically just sugar
sugar sugar sugar and water
sugar water corn syrup vinegar maltose
put them all in this pot boil them up
until it becomes this thick
gooey liquid that we're then going to
shape into
candy i also got burn relief gel
because i wasn't sure if i would burn
myself so one step at a time
if i remember correctly what i'm
supposed to do so sugar first
i get every single bit maltose super
gooey that's what it looks like
[Music]
from the videos and the recipes i saw
i'm supposed to turn this on
and then not stir it if you stir it the
sugar is going to crystallize and if it
crystallizes
you're screwed and that is a big no no
oh my god
okay so now i'm supposed to just leave
it running
i'm not the most patient person in the
world so
it's about 225. looks like a little
volcano you can only look at it
which is what i'm doing i'm looking at
it but it's so slow
i think i might have cooked it for too
long that's 277. i don't know if we're
screwed i'm gonna pour this into the
silicone mold
oh my god
[Music]
okay oh that was not a good idea we're
going to let it cool down
for a little bit we are back in business
the cornstarch is to keep it from
sticking together here we go
i think it's ready oh look at that this
is what it looks like right now
very very pliable we're gonna poke a
hole through this
cover it in starch ooh that feels nice
we're gonna shape it into a ring keep
doing this and then twisting it
one ring becomes two rings two rings
becomes four rings
up until we get sixteen 000 rings that
sounds really ambitious it is look good
so far
[Music]
twist it now we have two rings we're
gonna keep
pulling it
oh my god in the trash guess that means
you're gonna do another one
here we go nope
[Music]
wait this means we have to come back
redo the sugar all right
next time we can cut i'm so sad
it's after work now i'm just gonna keep
on doing this can't just give up my dad
didn't bring me up like that
i cooked the sugar less this time last
time i couldn't even get it this big
feels good stretchy stretchy two
two two four oh look at that it's
stretching there's no cracks
i think it might actually work four plus
four eight to sixteen
it definitely feels very flexible
32 right oh my god it's
so much better than the first batch
maybe they just don't want me to succeed
in front of people 32 plus 32
is 64. and it looks like it's going
somewhere
128.
pulling it 256. looks like it's working
512 1024.
you see that i couldn't even get past
two last time 2048.
this is really working my muscles for
1096.
8192 so close
last one 16 384
yo yeah
16k i did it
should we go one more thirty-two
thousand seven hundred
sixty-eight here it is it's like a
dragon's beard
this looks like a 400 thread count
egyptian cotton
bed sheet so gorgeous now we're gonna
fill it with peanut filling oh i'm so
excited
it looks like whiskers take a strand put
it in here
there's a tiny little bite right there
does somebody want to try this it's
really good
yes i'm so happy
i think we have to give up on person
number three
[Music]
hi i'm inka i really like bento boxes
recently i found some super super super
cute ones on the internet so i decided
to challenge
myself to see if i could make a super
cute bento box i've never made bento
boxes before
i definitely don't think it's going to
be easy i'm hoping
that my bento box looks at least a
little bit presentable
a bento box that hopefully people will
think is too cute to eat
all right so let's go so the first step
before i did anything else
was to buy a bento box
this is my bento box if you make a cute
bento your bento box has to be cute i
also got a couple of
shape cutouts including this panda face
one flower
star cutouts and some cute faces
the bento box materials also came with a
pair of tweezers
and a pin i don't know what this pin is
going to be used for
the next thing was to buy ingredients so
i got carrots i got tomatoes
kale cheese ham and sausages
rice seaweed and some tofu skin let's
get started so i'm going to start off
with the little sausages
we're gonna create little octopuses i'm
supposed to just cut
eight feet out i uh tore his leg
i don't know how i already messed up
maybe i should do this this is not
safe eight legs
i'm also gonna prep the eggs
we're gonna make an egg omelet a lot of
bento boxes that i saw on the internet
include this it looks pretty and it's a
great source of protein
i'm gonna add some dried vegetables
i am like the clumsiest person in the
world wait it's been 20 minutes
that's because i dropped stuff oh i'll
be a breeze from here i'm sure
all right sausages looks like a little
octopus
all right i think that's done just gonna
let them cool down a little bit
next up make the egg omelette i've only
done this like two times before
please don't burn slowly fold this up
oh my god then we got to do it again i
really want to get that nice
layered oval shape that i see in the
bento box videos
egg omelet we have the first two things
done
so what i'm gonna try and do right now
is to shape little rice balls
oh my god the rice is all caught in my
hand
help me help you become human beings
squish
we have our ice balls so now what i'm
going to try to do
is to form little hats with this put it
on top of the rice ball think of like a
tofu skin
beanie we want to do something like this
this is not my trick i learned it from
youtube guys
this is slippery not as quick as i
thought it would be
i'm gonna try to put the beanies on the
little rice balls put that in there
now it looks like a little hat keeping
the rice ball warm
i'm gonna cut out faces for both the
rice ball beans
and also the hats so i'm going to use
the ham and the cheese
and then for little details i'll have to
cut it out using seaweed this should be
pretty simple
it's just cutting shapes out right
how do i get this out this is what this
is for right
oh yes perfect cheese circle
it's like glue mayo is my glue right now
there we go
i feel like these beanies are giving up
on me too
[Music]
okay i'm not touching it again i don't
want to don't want to destroy it then
we're going to do the eyes for the
little sausages
my hands are shaking looks like eyeballs
they're kind of creepy looking just
gonna cut out some cheeks
here we go they're not the best looking
things but they look presentable this is
taking a lot more time than i thought it
would
but we're making good progress so i got
a piece of seaweed
we're gonna try cutting out these faces
nope didn't make a dent in it
[Music]
trying the other face how long should i
do this for
it should work amazon said they would
work amazon never lies
[Music]
how about like metal
[Music]
i just broke it
nope
[Music]
this is my backup and if this doesn't
work
i'm going to run out and get something
else i don't know what fingers crossed
[Music]
that sounds promising
yes yeah
trim the mouths my hands are legit
shaking
there we go first mouth
need me some eyes right now
can he just have bigger eyes because i
can't cut
i for
did the eye just fly out
how is it possible that people do this
every day
[Music]
they look cute right yeah
yeah sorry i'm too excited
now i just gotta finish off the sausages
guys the octopus
has arrived oh yes
i'm just going to cut up the egg cut up
the carrots
and we're going to put them all together
i am so tired my back hurts
but i feel so accomplished
let's assemble put some kale in
start by putting in the little people
we're gonna put in the eggs
and then we're going to put in the
little sausages
[Music]
cherry tomatoes last thing the pretty
flower carrots
[Music]
and there you have it kind of cute i'm
pretty proud of myself i spent two and a
half hours
i did not expect to be here for so long
big shout out to people who do this
every day
so much respect for you will i ever do
this for my kids no
i am done i'm done hey guys it's inca
i'm back again this time to make another
crazy cool
dessert thing i was just scrolling
through my instagram and i
found this really cool flower looking
cake think of like a raindrop cake but
with
a rose inside it looks really
complicated
so i thought why not try and make it
myself what i did find
was an online tutorial by gelatin art
market
i will work really hard and try and try
and try again
until i make it happen so let's get
started for the gelatin base there's a
couple things we need
gelatin powder this one says super clear
citric acid
lots of sugar water flavoring i chose
lemon i think it'll add like a
nice citrus touch three tablespoons of
gelatin
and one cup of cold water and then just
mix it and stir this until there's
no more clumps left
oh so i'm gonna put that aside we're
gonna start boiling the
water and sugar three cups of water
nobody felt tasty okay two cups of sugar
one teaspoon
of citric acid turn it on get a spoon
and stir it until the sugar dissolves
gelatin in the meanwhile
it is now quite firm once i see steam
i'm supposed to stop
oh there is steam we have our beautiful
gelatin here it is now completely in
solid form
[Music]
throw it in there now we're just
stirring that together add a little bit
of flavoring
this is pretty much done so i let it
cool for a little bit
we're just gonna pour it into these
little containers that i bought
in order to have enough backup if i
screw up tomorrow i'm gonna make a lot
just to be safe
[Music]
i'm gonna wrap these up and put it in
the fridge and we'll be back tomorrow
for the really really hard part until
then
i'm gonna get a good night's sleep and
see y'all tomorrow
it is now the second day and we are back
here
to check on the gelatin i pulled them
out from the fridge
and guess what it's not falling out it
looks clear which is what you want for a
base
i also made this huge tub of gelatin
just for practice so let's go into the
color making segment we'll see how the
rest of this goes kind of like what we
did with the gelatin base i need one
tablespoon of gelatin powder
now we need three tablespoons of cold
water we're gonna throw in the sugar
the milk let it heat up so now we have
the heated milk and sugar looks a little
translucent i'm gonna put the gelatin in
now
slowly melt it down add the remaining
half cup
of cold milk we have to add the white
food coloring makes it
appear less translucent we're supposed
to um
blend this in does this work it does
work
[Music]
put this in
i don't know this is a good idea oh my
god
oh yeah okay i think we have the color
base
so i have a couple of bottles of food
coloring here just went with some
classic
flower colors green for in case i feel
ambitious enough to make
leaves it's just like working with
frosting we have our color
palette ready not sure if the
consistency is right yet but
we're moving forwards let's get to
flower making i have
gelatin art tools which are supposed to
help me because they're already shaped
like petals
but we're going to start off using this
all right that's color i'm gonna need
some tissue
oh my god that looks like blood this is
not a good color to start with
okay really bad choice of color the idea
was to
poke this in and then this color is
terrifying me
but look so that's kind of what we're
going for if i
no how do i do this the gelatin is
working the color is working
it's just that my hands aren't working i
look like i just killed somebody let's
try that again
how am i supposed to draw a petal well i
guess that could be a cool design that
looks like a cool flower i didn't even
do that though
i don't know how i did it hold on i need
to do some retraining really quick
oh they're holding it like this
it looks better
no i broke it i got a little too excited
i just have these like deformed petals
in this little tub i should have made a
bigger tub
i'm gonna try using this i'll plug it
into this
these tools are supposed to help you so
i'm hoping
this will actually make it look more
like a flower
you see that okay this is so much easier
than a needle
we're gonna test it out on one of the
other practice little bowls i made
so here we have clear bowl we're gonna
put this in
i'm just gonna keep going
i'm getting color all over my hands how
does that look
as a little baby flower you guys it
looks good right
this makes me feel really good i'm gonna
try and take it out
let me just warm it up a little this is
supposed to be the method to take it out
oh my god
flip it yes
look at that i know it's not much but
we went from this to this so i'm pretty
pretty happy right now i'm so excited i
think we can make this work
let's try working on a second one round
two let's do it i'm gonna start off with
actually this
a flower center well i can feel like
adrenaline
pumping through my veins oh
yes got the center in which one looks
most like a rose
please don't mess this up put this here
do you see that it's like a little rose
petal i have little gelatin bits it's
not a good sign
i'm just supposed to build around this
right
looking good so far i'm so nervous
oh no i added too much color it's okay
it's okay it's okay it's okay
refill oh my god
oh my god shaking i'm just gonna
concentrate not talk for a bit
let's try to get this to work this is so
nerve-wrecking this is what it looks
like so far
i don't know how i got to this point it
looks like a real rose
it even has like random spots on it that
makes it look more real
i'm so surprised oh no it's coagulating
this is what happens when it sits here
for a while it becomes
clumpy that splotch was great that's why
i'm trying to put them in like this
pan of water so then i can control their
consistency they were saying this is the
best way to warm it up
reheating reheating reheating
nice let's get back to business
oh no i tore it i tore the gelatin so
that is my
cue to stop should we flip it what if i
can't get it out
here we go
[Music]
oh that was anticlimactic sorry
in the beginning it looked really good
and then as i moved outwards
it just became worse and worse but i
think for
a second attempt it still looks really
cool we're getting somewhere gonna keep
going
we kind of made a rose i know we could
do one that's better but i wanted to try
something different kind of want to
mess around with the white and yellow
make like a daisy but not really
let's do this just right in the middle
oh my god can chill out
[Music]
so nervous do i know what i'm doing no
i'm just trying to be creative
[Music]
it looks pretty cool changing colors to
white
oh
let's do it
[Music]
holy moly a preview of what is about to
come this
takes time and patience all of the stuff
that
i have limited amounts of
oh my god cold sweat
once you get going there's no stopping
more more we're getting there i think
slowly but surely let's go for another
layer
so far this is what we have i really
want this to work
it has to work just keep going
just keep going
ready
i'm just gonna add some leaves it's a
little ambitious i might completely mess
up the whole thing
but if this works this is gonna be
magical
that is not the sound of success please
don't mess up
here goes nothing
[Music]
so it looks like from the bottom but
hold on i think we can make this work
[Music]
subconsciously holding my breath one
more leaf
oh my god here it is
this is what it looks like with the
leaves i'm gonna try and cover the base
with white
this is supposed to help the color pop
i'm nervous
oh my god help i'm gonna put this in the
fridge
and we'll check on it in a bit moment of
truth the white color base has set we're
gonna try and flip this around
this is gonna be the ultimate flower i'm
so nervous
if this messes up i'm gonna have to do
it all over again
i don't wanna rush it
you guys how's that look it looks pretty
legit
i really did not think i would be able
to do this i am super happy
right now give me one second all right
i have all the flowers i made it looks
like a little garden
really not the easiest things to make
it's been a roller coaster ride
would you eat it would i eat it
i'm gonna eat one right now here we go
this is what it looks like it's a little
bit jiggly but
tastes like lime jello let me know what
you guys think if you think i did a good
job
what else you guys want me to make and
i'll see y'all next time
hey guys it's aka i'm back at it again
today i'm actually going to make a giant
cotton candy flower
which was also something i saw on the
streets of china it's exactly as you
would imagine it's just layers and
layers of cotton candy until it builds
up into this huge
candy flower as you guys know i am not
the best at this
but i do give it my best shot let's go
so we have the cotton candy machine the
sugar scooper and we also have
different colored cotton candy sugar
start the machine
need to let it warm up i don't really
have a lot of experience making cotton
candy i think i've only made it once
before
also in china because they use skewers
instead of cones i'm also going to be
using
this i'm just going to do a warm up
actually this is a bit hard to scoop
[Music]
okay that's much prettier just going to
test this first one
[Music]
terrifying this is your normal cotton
candy now i need to do
a not normal one the ultimate goal is
huge that's high it's hard
15 layers let's try this you just have
to spin
really fast
holy moly is this normal
oh i forgot to put water on the stick
it's falling off
nope nope nope nope i'm getting
connected kenny everywhere i'm gonna do
it a sketch
it all went on my hand how much is there
this is what is going on right now
i actually don't know how i'm going to
be able to do this all my stress
on my stress you see let's try that
again
[Music]
how did he do this so you'd kind of just
fold you just need to make it look like
a flower this is look like a pi
[Applause]
[Music]
continue
you fold it up like that as long as it
looks like it has
five or six petals
i have to make like 15 layers of this
[Music]
this is this is getting a bit much okay
so now i fold it again
i need a oh it looks so good on camera
we're doing the right thing the key is
to spin really fast
[Music]
that's it so we're gonna fold it again i
feel like it's about to fall off
but that just means we need to keep on
going it's too big
um i feel like you're beginning to not
be able to see the layers it looks
i'm gonna keep on going this is like a
panic attack every time
i'm aiming for 15. we have one two three
four
five
six down nine more to go here we go
oh this one smells like funky grape
help help tissue okay this one's a
little gross
but i'm gonna keep on going oh my god
i have cotton candy all the way up to my
elbow
my hand has become part of the stick
so far we have eight this is the eighth
layer i feel like it's beginning to melt
i'm just going to start
speed doing this
[Music]
i feel like i have candy all over my
face
ten it's starting to look like a giant
dumpling
five more oh my god i'm getting
delusional
i don't go lifting enough to do this
i am holy moly starting to get a little
too big to handle i think we're pretty
much there
should i do one more where should you
quit while you're ahead
that is not the spirit can you see my
face
[Music]
why am i why am i doing that why why no
stop okay
one more layer just to wrap it up it's
gonna be huge
[Music]
it's done it's already started
to blend together at least i got to this
point
yum these people who do it in china
they're super precise
they're super detailed i'm pretty proud
and i will see you all next time
hey guys it's inka today we're going to
be doing something a little bit
different
my friend aday gave me an ostrich egg
he challenged me to make a giant
egg mcmuffin we only have one ostrich
egg it is not a cheap egg
the steaks are very high but let's make
it work we're gonna start off by making
the
english muffin part so i looked up some
recipes and i made the dough last night
so here's the dough flour moment of
truth
[Music]
look at how much air this has i'm gonna
knead this gently
oh it's so smooth
i need to roll this out
gonna roll it like pizza
[Music]
that looks pretty decent they said
sprinkle
pretty generously i think i'm being very
generous it smells so good and we're
gonna cut it
[Music]
so this is what it looks like right now
this is the muffin
[Music]
we're gonna let this proof for a little
over an hour
we can start working on the ostrich
you hear that like a china plate very
smooth
even though it has bigger pores than i
[Music]
do
it's beginning to crack
[Music]
oh my god the membrane why is it so full
i don't know what to do
i'm shaking
[Music]
it looks like egg that was the hardest
part
i'm gonna pour this in the mold now i'm
gonna put it in the oven okay
oh my god it's leaking oh my god
[Music]
we're gonna go 350. maybe a little lower
okay let's check on that later
we're going to transfer this huge piece
of bread to the cast iron how does one
transfer this
no no no flip it
wow that was a complete and utter flavor
we're just gonna wait now
until it becomes golden brown
think it's about that time look at that
yay
wow
put it on this preheated making sheet
pop it in the oven bye bye see you later
it's all coming together now our
beautiful ostrich
oh so excited
so while i'm waiting for these to cool
down i am going to
pan fry these super thick cut by thick i
mean
damn let's just perfect
for a giant egg muffin
okay so you're only supposed to open
these with
a fork so i found a giant
forkish thing let's try
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm so happy so we're gonna butter these
slices up
make it extra greasy extra yummy hey
these are going back in the oven i'm
super excited so we're gonna
do the most important part now for
research purposes
the original egg mcmuffin you see the
bread on top the ham the egg the cheese
so that's how we're gonna build ours
here we go
i could not find a giant piece of cheese
so
we're gonna have to do this one by one
this is the moment we've been waiting
for
[Music]
done
wow how do you take this off whoa
now we're gonna put the ham
i'm gonna cover it up and this
my friends is the beautiful giant
egg mcmuffin the only thing missing is
that we need to get the cheese just like
this
super melty
wow original one it looks kind of alike
right
wow guys i did it i didn't think i would
be able to do it but i did it the real
test is does it taste like it we don't
know i'm gonna have my friends and my
co-workers reveal the truth
i'm nervous
this thing itself is the size of an egg
mcmuffin
really it tastes exactly like a necklace
yeah we did it until next time
bye bye the body of the dragon
oh i'm so nervous
oh so nervous
hey guys it's inka so last time i made
dragonbeard's candy today
i'm gonna try painting with sugar
sugar painting has been around for
centuries it is this amazing art form
where people use sugar to paint
different characters
anything from rabbits to monkeys to
dragons when i was traveling around
china i saw these artists on the streets
and i thought it was the most
amazing thing i am not really an artist
i don't even have a recipe for this
so i'm just going to be winging it it's
going to be great sugar painting
first things first i have no idea what
sugar i'm gonna use so i'm just going to
test out different types and different
ratios
for our first attempt we're gonna go
with one cup of rock sugar
and one cup of water i think i'm
supposed to boil the water first
here we go
i feel like you need a little bit more
i'm supposed to continue stirring this
[Music]
now it's looking a lot stickier you see
that
hope it means we're on the right track
yeah i'm gonna turn it down now
i'm just wondering if it's supposed to
bubble this much this doesn't look like
the right
color did i overcook it oh my god it is
crystallizing
i failed let's go for round two
round two we are going to do one cup of
sugar
and two cups of water fingers crossed
i'm gonna go with white sugar this time
i am not gonna stir it
we'll see how that goes so right now we
have this sticky
gooey looking liquid it's not quite the
right color
but it was better than our first attempt
get some out
and put it into cold water
it's hot tastes good but i don't think
it's what we're looking for i can't
really draw with this this is not
how it's supposed to be we have failed
yet again
i don't know what to do to make this
right i don't know what i'm doing wrong
i can't even figure out the sugar how
can i get to painting we're gonna end it
here
and try something different yeah we can
cut
i am freaking out right now because we
were gonna give up
for the day and i had cut all the
cameras so
i'm on my phone right now but look at
this look
at this color oh my god i'm so excited
right now
one second i'm gonna pour it out here we
[Music]
oh my go this has been such a good shot
it's so
beautiful
look at this i'm just gonna break it
apart
like it tastes like what i had
i am so excited so i broke them into
little pieces
i can see it right there and now i am
going to
reset everything back up clean all the
dishes and we're gonna start painting
yay so we're rolling again i have my
sugar candy bits
in this mason jar you could totally eat
this as is it smells really good i'm
just gonna melt it
on low heat this might take a while
[Music]
does this look like drawing consistency
[Music]
i think so i think we might be ready my
main goal today
is to draw a dragon that is like the
ultimate
goal but we're gonna have to do some
practicing first i should probably start
with something easier
let's try
[Music]
this is me trying to draw a butterfly
that's the easiest thing i can think of
this is a bad butterfly wow i wanted to
go from this to a dragon i think we're
being very
optimistic here oh i know it's not much
to look at
but it's my first please bear with me
this is the first of its kind this could
belong to like the moma
right let's do this
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh my god we're so close a little bit
more just a little bit more
[Music]
okay this one looks a little bit more
like a butterfly
i'm scared
[Music]
come on up the best way
oh
[Music]
does it look like a butterfly
we're slowly getting there this is so
stressful
it is about time for me to
really go out there and do the dragon
only got one shot so let's try
i'm so nervous oh
so nervous
[Music]
come on
i don't even know if i can lift it up
huh
[Music]
so this is what we have so far now the
challenge
is to pick it up i am so nervous right
now
i don't even know where to start
[Music]
glue it back oh my god
oh my god
here we go it's all or nothing
guys i can't believe i did it
it's a freaking dragon i'm like so
scared i'm gonna drop it
[Music]
i i can't believe i actually
did what i thought was impossible i
definitely burned the sugar towards the
end definitely a lot of room for
improvement but i'm pretty satisfied hey
guys it's inka so today i'll be making
this thing called kohakuto which is this
super cool looking candy from japan
what's really interesting about these
candies is that it actually ends up
looking almost like glass it takes on
this like translucent quality which i
thought was
pretty awesome hopefully they will look
as
pretty as i saw them to be
let's get going again this recipe is
fairly simple we only really need three
ingredients
we need some sort of liquid you could
use water if you want i chose
a passion fruit pear juice i figured
this would give it a little bit more
fruity flavor agar agar which works kind
of like
gelatin but it's made of completely
different things it also helps give
whatever you're making that jelly-like
quality we also need
as per usual a lot of sugar
i promise it will be really good and
really sweet like very sweet we're going
to turn this on
and pour the juice in first passion
fruit smells so good
now we're gonna add the agar agar stir
it gently
so then the agar doesn't stick to the
bottom three to five minutes i would say
while we're waiting for that i wanted to
show you guys a couple of molds that i
bought i bought these
gem shaped molds if we poured the candy
mixture into here
it would pop out as gems i also have
these these are actual earring molds and
these are like
necklace like amulet molds i don't know
if this is going to work this is just me
trying to be creative fingers crossed
molds aside i also have just a regular
pan that i oiled a little bit so it
doesn't stick this should be
there's some steam coming out it's time
for sugar this is
a lot of sugar it's like a little
mountain this is still on super low heat
slowly melt this down let the sugar
dissolve just gonna let it slowly heat
up
[Music]
all righty it is now boiling it's
slightly thicker we're gonna have to
run this through a mesh strainer
oh that's good that tastes like passion
fruit candy
it's so good okay so this is the part
where we have to work kind of fast
i am actually going to try to fill these
up first here goes nothing
i don't want to accidentally spill it
as i say that i spilled it i'm using
this dropper
we're gonna go in with this
i'm like super slow right now better
safe than sorry better slow than sorry
great sound i'm just gonna fill up a
little bit of these
and then the rest i'm just gonna pour it
in here now we've poured all the candy
out we're gonna go in with some food
coloring
to make it look pretty where's my food
coloring oh it's right here it would
actually be such a cool idea to try
and make infinity stones like in
avengers
let's do this gonna start off with red
let's see if this works
oh it's so pretty orange
yellow green blue and then purple
there we have the infinity stones quote
unquote and we can make a rainbow in
this one
so i'm just gonna splash these on let's
try to blend these
together this is looking super nice guys
it's like tie-dye but like with candy
same thing with these ones
oh no it's already solidifying i'm just
not gonna mess with these because
i think i waited too long so we're just
gonna focus on the necklaces
just going to add a bit of color and
swirl it a little bit make them look
pretty i don't know if i'm really
being successful with that right now
kind of just winging this
you have to work really fast with these
you just pour it out in a pan that's
probably the easiest thing to do so what
i'm gonna do now is actually put it in
the fridge
let it chill for two hours hopefully it
sets after it sets
we'll try to pop them out if they're
intact
then we can go from there off to the
fridge you go
time to chill okay so it's been two
hours
i just pulled these from the fridge they
have now completely solidified
it looks pretty good actually looks the
exact same as it did two hours ago
only difference is that it's not falling
out really thankful that actually didn't
fall out these are also now
in solid form there's a nice shine to it
it's a bit floppy the trick here now is
to take it out carefully
and hope that it stays intact knowing me
there is a huge chance that we might
actually break these here goes nothing
let's try to pop these out oh this is so
slowly but surely
oh my god oh my god oh
there we go do you see that right now it
doesn't really look gem like it just
looks like
jello shaped in a gem form it will get
there
but for right now i'm just happy that it
came out in one piece so we're gonna set
this down
here here's our green one basically
that's it we're just gonna slowly take
all of these out
love this one it looks so pretty the
purple
really just looks black
infinity stones this is my geek moment
okay now i'm gonna put this down before
i drop it
oh guys
that is pretty cool you can see the hole
in the middle we can
easily make this into a necklace the
color came out
so cool though yes turned out pretty
cool
i'm feeling good about this i hope this
streak continues
our rainbow one tada it looks so cool
i'm gonna pop these earring ones out oh
two little teardrops
hopefully we can actually make these
into earrings so i'm gonna set these
here
now for this one we just need to
carefully try to take it out and i can
cut it into strips
how do you take this out it's tearing
apart
no no no no no no
i tore it this is what it looks like
this is what my hand looks like
that's okay cut this like so
i could just tear this just to get that
like jagged
glass effect so these are our little
broken shards
cut these into square shapes that is
a perfect square shape
i have a small strip left i have these
little flower cutouts
that i'm gonna use just like this
this is what it looks like a little
flower
i'm just going to keep on doing these
cut a couple
out look at this one look at that color
i'm just going to add a couple more it's
so pretty
last one all right here we have it
the total amount of candy that we made
today there's our infinity stones
the necklace pieces our little earrings
and a lot of little flowers star shapes
rectangular shapes
glass pieces i think today ended pretty
good
the next step really is just patience
because we have to wait four to six days
for these to dry out completely
now the drying process begins i will see
you guys
in four to six days we are back here
today the kohaku toe has hardened
i can sort of peel it off it's like a
matte color now smooth surface
gently
it feels a little less fragile see how
it doesn't stick together anymore
that's what it looks like now it's
actually turned on pretty well it like
crystallized
a little bit more i don't know if you
guys can hear it
but this is the sound that it makes now
these bigger ones
it's kind of opaque these are the
trickier ones
oh okay hold on it looks pretty cool
doesn't really look like a perfect
circle anymore i'm just glad it's still
in one piece
infinity stones ta-da here we have all
of the infinity stones
nerd moment again now that i have all of
them
now that we have all these pieces i'm
gonna try turning some of these into
actual jewelry these are some little
necklaces and then we also have some
earring things not entirely sure how
this is gonna play out but
let's uh give it a shot let's just see
if these work
oh can you see it can you see it
let's see if i can put this through a
necklace go ahead and go in go in i got
it through
i am not somebody who normally wears
accessory i am not
not somebody who normally wears
accessories so this is a
how does it look i did not think this
was actually going to work this is
really cool
play with your food candy earrings
totally edible i'm just going to take a
bite
because this is edible jewelry after all
look fancy and still kept
looks fancy but it's also very fragile
maybe we'll try some more
be ambitious because these worked out
really well as you guys can see
you can really customize this in
whatever way you want do different
colors different flavors different
shapes
and really just have fun with it i'm
still wearing this so i'm going to take
these off now and
maybe not eat them i'm really glad i did
this today really glad we were able to
pull it off and
see you guys next time
[Music]
you